Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain an American science fiction film
called “Planet of the Apes 2001.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
The premise of the movie is set in the year 2029.
Captain Leo Davidson is an astronaut aboard the
United States Air Force space station, Oberon.
He and his team are with apes who are specially
trained for space missions. At the beginning
of the movie, we are introduced to one of such
chimpanzees named Pericles. He works closely
with the captain and is very good at his job.
Leo receives a video message from his friends on
earth but while watching it, the lights go out and
the electronic devices start to malfunction. The
flickering of the lights causes the animals aboard
to panic. Leo is asked to report to the bridge to
discuss the malfunction. He is then informed about
an electromagnetic storm approaching the space
station. The standard procedure is to send an ape
to take initial radiation and gamma-ray readings
and make sure the storm is safe for a human
astronaut to approach. Leo’s superior asks him to
get Pericles ready for the trip. Leo retaliates
and claims that it is his job as a captain to
report the initial readings but everyone else
asks him to follow the standard procedure.
He then prepares Pericles for the mission. The
creature is seated in a small pod that he pilots
to the storm. Only some minutes after the takeoff,
the scientists notice that the pod is off course
and Pericles’s heart rate is rising. Eventually,
they lose the track of the pod and declare that it
is lost. Leo sneaks into a pod and launches into
space to get the chimp even though his superiors
ask him to return. He gets a visual of the pod
that Pericles is in but before he can report it,
his pod crashes into a massive foreign object.
After the impact, he loses all signals from the
space station. He, yet again crashes into a bright
wormhole. The pod malfunctions and crashes into a
planet's surface that looks a lot like the earth.
Leo lands on a water body and somehow survives
the crash. He walks around exploring the forest
he is in. The first person he meets is a man
who seems to be a native of the jungle. The
man and a group behind him are running away
from wild apes who are chasing them.
Without thinking much about it, Leo also starts to
run with them. The apes wear armor for protection
and seem to be more advanced than humans. They
abduct most of the group as the surviving ones
try to run away. All of them, including Leo, are
eventually enslaved and taken away in a human-run
carriage. They reach a civilization of humanoid
apes where humans are used for household works
and entertainment and the apes run the society.
The ape kids throw stones at the captured humans
calling them dirty. We are introduced to a female
ape, Ari who supports human rights and protests
the way they are treated in society. She scolds
the kids and tells them to respect all beings.
The slaves are then sold to a dealer. After they
are put into the cages, a little ape child buys a
human girl to keep her as a pet. The adults are
dragged out and marked with a hot iron stick.
Ari intervenes and asks the dealer to be less
ruthless to humans because they also have rights.
Leo takes this opportunity to grab the
iron rod and hold her hostage. He whispers
to her to help him escape this place.
A human girl named Daena also tries to run away
but is caught by the dealer. He claims that he
will have to put down both Leo and Daena. To save
their lives, Ari asks the dealer to sell them to
her. The dealer is reluctant at first but agrees
anyway. Ari’s father is a well-respected senator
who doesn’t like that Ari has brought two wild
humans into his house. He asks her to keep them
in check because he will soon have guests over.
One of the guests is General Thade, a sadistic
chimpanzee military commander who wants control
over the ape civilization. When Leo and Daena are
alone in the kitchen, he asks her how the monkeys
managed to get more powerful than humans. Daena
claims that they have always been that way. Leo
is then taken outside to serve the guests.
As the guests engage in a conversation, Leo
overhears Thade saying that humans outnumber apes
by a large number. Ari puts forward her ideas of
equality between humans and apes but Thade claims
that her principles threaten the ape’s prosperity.
When Leo comes to serve the table, Thade
forcefully opens his mouth and mocks him.
Ari leaves the table at the sight and Thade
follows her behind. It turns out that he has
been asking her to marry him for quite some time
but because of his cold soul, she refuses.
After dinner, Leo and Daena are locked inside
a cage with the house slaves. At night,
Leo manages to open the cage and run away with
Daena and the other humans. Daena insists that
she won’t run away without her family who is still
locked up in the dealership. They run to the said
dealership and free her father and the other
human slaves. Following that, the group makes
their way to the forest. Soon, the soldiers are
ordered to look for the escaped prisoners. The
murderous General Thade and his junior, Colonel
Attar, march ape warriors to pursue the humans.
While trying to run away, the group bumps into
Ari who agrees to help them at Leo’s request.
However, before they can escape through a tunnel,
Colonel Attar approaches them. Daena’s father, who
is already very injured, runs to fight the ape and
distract him. He sacrifices his life in the fight
but because of him, the others run away safely.
Leo takes them to the lake that he had landed in.
We find out that the apes are terrified of water
because they cannot swim. Leo and Daena swim into
the Lake and retrieve a bag from the crashed pod.
It contains a gun and a beacon that Leo uses to
send a signal to the space station. He receives
data that says that the space station is already
in the atmosphere, most probably looking for him.
Just then, the dealer Limbo attacks them and tries
to abduct one of the humans. Leo threatens him
with the gun and holds him hostage because if they
let him go, he will lead the others to the group.
After that, they continue to follow the signal
received by the beacon to help Leo go back
home. Meanwhile, back in the town, Thade
asks the senator for absolute power to eradicate
the humans. He wants to take the opportunity to
expand his power and eventually rule the world
of apes. The senator believes that his daughter
was abducted by the humans, so he does as Thade
says and provides him with full authority.
Thade’s father gets severely sick so he is called
to meet him. In his place, General Krull goes to
stop the humans. Thade’s father is the only man he
trusts and respects. The old ape knows something
that the younger generation doesn’t. Thade asks
his father about the source of his knowledge.
The father ape then tells him about the first
of their kind named the Semos. Before the
arrival of Semos, the apes were the slaves to
humans who ruled the society. Thade believes
it to be impossible but his father continues the
explanation. He reveals a hidden old gun and says
that humans possess the power of invention and
technology which is greater than their strength.
The old ape begs his son to not let the humans
get to a place called the Calima. It is the holy
temple of Semos that holds the secret of their
true origin. If the humans find out about it,
they will retaliate and destroy the ape’s world.
In the meantime, the group of escapees makes
their way to Camila where Leo believes his team is
waiting for him. When they reach closer, they see
scarecrows made to keep the apes and the humans
away from the holy temple. They finally get to
a checkpoint where camps of apes have been settled
to guard the way to the temple. General Krull also
arrives there and takes command of the troops.
When the sun sets, Leo creates a distraction using
his gun and makes his way to the camp on horses.
He and the group manage to set the camp on fire
and cross the river which is the only obstacle
between them and the temple of Semos. A while
later, Thade arrives at the camp and is furious at
the troops for not being able to stop the humans.
He gathers them all and sets off to look for the
enemies from the other side of the mountain. The
escapees, on the other hand, rest for the night
and reach the Semos’s temple the next day. Leo is
beyond surprised when he sees that the temple is
actually the space station, Oberon, that he left
a few days ago. Ari claims that it is impossible
because the temple has been there for thousands
of years. Since the station is powered by nuclear
energy, Leo is able to retrieve visual logs to see
what actually happened to his ship. Then, he finds
out that when he entered the wormhole, he jumped
through time and reached the year 5021. The Oberon
remained in the year 2029 and looked for him. They
were never able to find him and the station
eventually crashed to this planet’s surface
in 2029. The apes that were aboard the Oberon went
wild and started to attack the crew members. But
eventually, one of the apes named Semos stopped
them and led the way. As time passed, the apes
took over and the people Leo is with currently
are the descendants of his fellow crew members.
Now, he has no way to return home. When he steps
out of the ruins of the Oberon, several humans
surround him. They have heard the story about the
brave human and want to help him fight the apes.
But Leo knows that they will not be able to win
against thousands of apes who are coming for them.
He asks them to run away but they stay put in
their decisions. Then, he thinks of an idea.
Since the Oberon has plenty of nuclear fuel, he
plans to use it to fire a final blast at apes when
they arrive. He makes all the humans hide behind
the spaceship and uses the escapees as bait to
invite the apes. When the first batch of apes is
close enough, the nuclear blast sends them flying.
However, soon after Thade and the second batch of
the army attack them. They start to overpower the
humans with their strength. Leo and Thade get
into a fierce battle but stop when they notice
a familiar ship landing from the sky. It contains
Pericles who had also been lost in the wormhole.
It turns out the electromagnetic storm actually
releases people from it in an opposite direction
in time to their entrance,that explains
why Pericles arrived a few days after Leo.
The apes then bow, interpreting his arrival as
the return of Semos, and hostilities between
humans and apes suddenly cease.
Ignoring everyone, Pericles runs into
the remains of the Oberon and Leo runs
after him, followed by General Thade.
Thade wants to end Pericles to attain absolute
power but Leo stops him. The two get into a fight.
Leo’s gun lands inside the pilot’s deck during the
struggle. Thade goes inside to retrieve it but is
trapped when Leo locks the automatic door. The
enraged ape fires the gun repeatedly at the door
but the ricochets create sparks that scare him. He
hides under a control panel, accepting his defeat.
Deciding to return to Earth, Leo gives Pericles
to Ari, who promises to look after him. He tells
everyone that humans and apes are supposed to
live in peace and harmony, it was Semos’s wish all
along. After saying farewell to Ari and Daena, Leo
climbs aboard Pericles's undamaged pod and travels
back in time through the same electromagnetic
storm, and crashes in Washington, D.C. on Earth.
He looks up at what appears to be the Lincoln
Memorial, only to find that it is now a monument
memorializing General Thade. A swarm of police
officers, firefighters, and news reporters,
all of whom are apes, descend upon him.
Now for the explanation of the ending..we
can assume that Leo has entered into the
future because of the electromagnetic storm.
It is likely that after Leo’s departure from
the previous planet, Thade somehow managed
to break free and travelled to Earth through the
same electromagnetic storm. He was then released
to earth thousands of years before Leo’s arrival.
Because the ape was kicked out of his planet,
he managed to rule the earth and overthrow
humans. And now everyone on earth is ape!
Subscribe for more videos like
this, turn on the notification,
and leave a like to help the channel
out. Thank You for watching.